et avec nous autres habitent et michel
habig comment allez-vous chaude est
ravie de vous accueillir vous êtes
conseiller départemental dans le canton
d'ensisheim avec votre binôme qui
s'appelle le bêti muller vous êtes
également le maire d'ensisheim
alors on va justement partir à la
découverte de ce canton d'ensisheim
comment est-il bien au programme visite
de la maison de la nature un nouvel
échangeur également sur l'a35 est plutôt
étonnant et on le détaillera de
l'électricité verte reportage d'adrien
la vie apothéose de l'art de la
fortification selon vauban la cité de
neuf brisach cette forteresse à une deux
milieu du rhin est sorti de terre en
1698 elle avait alors pour but de
protéger le royaume de france des
assauts venues d'outre-rhin
aujourd'hui classé au patrimoine mondial
de l'unesco le village neuf brisach est
un des joyaux du canton d'ensisheim
ouvert en 1831 le canal du rhône au rhin
est longtemps restée un axe de
communication majeur
cette partie entre mulhouse et
strasbourg a été déclassée dans les
années 60 est acquis par le département
qui fait aujourd'hui installé des
turbines hydrauliques produisant
l'électricité
notre vent debout devant une des
turbines donc sur les cluses 46 qui est
donc une des cinq turbines qui ont été
installés par le département sachant
qu'actuellement il y en a trois qui sont
en fonction depuis 2015 et les deux
suivantes mon se mettre en service
prochainement
une seule turbine produit l'équivalent
de la consommation d'un petit village
comme celui de galles ça sert 330
habitants sur une année alors ces
turbines ont été construites par
l'entreprise selon mme berger de
guebwiller qui est donc une entreprise
locale qui de par cette production et
cette invention a de son côté aussi
réussi à développer est vraiment dans
l'air du temps avec les énergies
renouvelables de communication vital
pour le département l'autoroute a35
l'accès à la voie rapide est un élément
important pour l'attractivité des
territoires ruraux le département
investit comme ici à niederentzen ou un
échangeur va bientôt ouvrir à la
circulation l'objectif de la réalisation
de cet échangeur autoroutier rentre dans
le projet global visant à améliorer la
desserte de l'entrée de rouffach par
l'autoroute mais également à améliorer
l'accessibilité au piémont des vosges et
sur ses deux zones l'attractivité sera
renforcée de par le biais de cet
échangeur ces travaux sont donc ont été
réalisés ce pour un coût de 3 millions
soit 750 et qui ont duré
deux années parce qu'ils ont débuté à
peu près en avril 2014 pour se terminer
là d'ici la fin du mois retour au bord
de l'ancien canal du rhône au rhin où
résonnent les cris d'enfants
nous sommes à la maison de la nature de
hirtzfelden depuis des années elle se
donne pour mission de faire découvrir la
faune et la flore aux plus jeunes
initialement installé dans une ancienne
maison éclusière il y a deux ans ce
magnifique bâtiment a pris le relais
avec le soutien du département
ne trouvant ici dans le labo nature du
la maison de la nature du vieux canal
qui appartient au département on peut
accueillir les scolaires
il ya effectivement aussi des animations
dans le cadre de l'euro citoyenneté et
de l'écocitoyenneté essentiellement se
soucier les animations qui peuvent avoir
lieu en forêt ou dans des endroits bien
propice à la faune et à la flore pour
découvrir un sujet bien précis
effectivement c'est un public de jeunes
mais aussi ouvert à tout un chacun qui
peut venir profiter de tout ce qui est
présenté est proposé dans cette maison
il a dans les faits pas d'âge pour
découvrir toute la richesse de la nature
voilà ça beaucoup trop quand même cher
très beau quand on boit vous il va
couvrir jetons en velours c'est tout
plat ouais je vous ai vu le commenter
même en voyant les images et que la
ligne bleue des vosges comme ça alors on
va rester sur des sujets d'actualité
dans votre canton c'est évidemment
fessenheim tout le monde en parle c'est
chez vous une usine tesla à la place de
la centrale comme l'a proposé récemment
la ministre de l'environnement usine
tesla pour construire des voitures créer
du développement économique est ce que
c'est crédible pour vous écouter on la
prend au mot c'est la ministre qui a
calé les cartes en main il faut qu'elles
viennent nous le proposait il ya du
terrain
on peut favoriser son accueil à côté de
fessenheim maintenant il est dit que ça
serait pas à côté de fessenheim si on
veut reconvertir fait sonné mais il faut
que les emplois ce soir créé à proximité
de fessenheim concrètement quel sera
l'impact de l'arrêt de la centrale sur
le territoire est assez énorme en terme
d'emplois déjà plus de 2000 emplois en
termes de revenus pour les collectivités
locales et en termes aussi de production
d'électricité je trouve moi
personnellement que c'est un non sens d'
arrêter cette centrale puisqu'elle
allait feu vert de l'autorité de sûreté
et donc il faut aller au bout elle
s'arrêtera un jour mais préparant sa
reconversion tranquillement et
sereinement candidats sur des coups
politiques et quand ségolène royal dit
effectivement il faut il faut un vrai
projet pour remplacer au d'affaires
fessenheim là on est d'accord t'as fait
on passe aux énergies renouvelables
j'ai découvert ces turbines qui
alimentait quand même d'un village de
330 habitants ce sont des minicentrales
hydroélectriques qu'on découvre encore
est ce que c'est quelque chose
l'idée géniale est ce que ça pourrait
être généralisé oui il faut de l'eau il
faut de l'eau à un débit régulier donc
là il y a deux trois mètres cubes
seconde mais sur toute l'année ce qui
fait l'intérêt de ces installations sur
le vieux canal et une chute donc les
anciennes écluses sont des chutes
étaient tout à fait approprié pour
accueillir ces turbines qui sont
vraiment une solution ingénieuse mise au
point par les équipes du département
avec la société jeu le berger le
nucléaire mais quand betty muller audi
que ça alimente 330
l'équivalent village à 100 habitants
c'est la turbine vu la vidéo j'ai le
jogging oui tout à fait voilà ça c'est
de l'avenir vous nous a fait découvrir
quelle condition d'avoir de l'eau et
puis de les geler apparente comme
voulant comme vous l'avez dit
neuf-brisach patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco depuis 2008 maintenant est-ce
que ça a un impact sur le tourisme la
rue d'abord c'est une une architecture
magnifique c'est vraiment quelque chose
vu du ciel c'est magique
il manque un ballon avait un projet va
venir peut-être qu'il va revenir alors
un ballon pour pau voir le la ville de 2
200 m 150 mètres de haut mais qu'est-ce
que ça qu'est ce que ça a changé mais le
jitem fall devrait faire tories est
maintenant sur tous les réseaux et donc
un touriste qui vient en alsace souhaite
aller voir neuf brisach voilà vous voyez
faire un vide
je pense que la municipalité de
neuf-brisach fait tout en ce moment pour
essayer de danse bien entretenir les
bonnes ces vestiges ses fortifications
et de les rendre accueillante ça
développe le tourisme la restauration
l'hôtellerie à plus de nuitées
il ya plus de nuitées y surtout plus de
touristes qui passent qui regardent et
une visite il faut encore améliorer les
conditions d'accueil et les circuits de
visite avec un petit tour en ballon
voulait demander vous avez voilà montrer
l'âge et enfin les travaux du nouvel
échangeur
denis guérin niederentzen en irak james
et de le dire mieux que moi et c'est
presque car c'est un très vieux projet
plus de vingt ans trente ans qu'on en
parle et il est maintenant terminée donc
on n'attend plus que le feu vert le
charme plus commode je l'avais vu de
d'un inspecteur général des ponts et
chaussées c'était quoi tant que c'est
fini c'est fini maintenant depuis
quelques semaines d'accord que ça ne
saurait tarder je ne saurait tarder moi
je dis il faut que ça qui soit ouvert au
mois de juin
sinon les habitants ne comprennent pas
il faut que ça serve à rien les choses
au sérieux tout à fait pourquoi on l'a
fait cet échangeur pour améliorer les
liaisons donc est-ouest nord-sud nous
sommes bien équipés avec la 83e
l'autoroute rd52 le long du rhin mais il
nous faut aller des transversales et
puis aussi permettant d'irriguer le côté
rouffach et le côté au ciné des reds n
est celle de fessenheim
voilà est ce que on il ya assez de
développement touristique dans votre
région est ce que votre canton c'est un
canton
on pourrait encore mieux faire on peut
encore mieux faire il ya tout tout les
conduire les activités de tourisme de
pleine nature un vélo course à pied le
long de l'ill long du canal de
désaffecter le rhin rhône le vieux canal
leur a aussi le long du rhin et
ensisheim météorite un beau petit musée
et de l'hôtellerie également qu'on ne
rencontre pas très loin l'écomusée le
pal du petit prince là vous êtes dans un
très très beau quoi ils ne durent pas
que la météorite est tombé à tisser
voilà ça ne s'invente pas merci beaucoup
aux michel habig ont été ravis de vous
accueillir